[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to my show
today is going to be pretty interesting
but before we jump in
it is powered by icon plus so quick news
announcement for you so
this month icon steve by project balance
will be released a user-friendly
platform that creates ics tokens
pegged to real-world assets like the
dollar gold and oil so always really
interesting there
it is also sponsored by block fights so
i want to say quick thank you to them um
i actually use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so um i've left a
link for you you can get 250
when you sign up so that's pretty cool
so joining me today before i bring him
on if you are watching
um on youtube then make sure you hit the
like button and hit subscribe so you
never miss any of these guests
now joining me today is author um he's
an entrepreneur um he's the guy with a
bunch of lambos and he's extremely
bullish on twitter and i also believe
it's his birthday
today jason what's up happy birthday
yeah what's going on happy birthday
like that's so random i had no idea yeah
it happens once a year
it's a it's not it's not that big a deal
as you get uh
to this advanced age uh but i'm gonna do
some partying now
so you know it's not you know i'm i'm
still uh i'm still trying to get after
it so how have you been i haven't talked
to you in a while
yeah i'm good i'm just still not over
the fact that it's your birthday and
you're working today
it's very sweet of you yeah this is like
a massive day
so it started off with um
beeple and his nft launch
on christy so i was really interested in
that
and um you know i was uh i was in the
market so just so
i i did go for it you know i'm not going
to say what i bid but
i knew some giga chad would ape in at
the end and it did it exactly
you know how i thought it would you know
i was a buyer
uh then the price went to 20 like four
million
and then with like five minutes left it
went to 50
and then it ended up at like 69 million
in chain
which is absolutely incredible isn't it
like i don't know where you are with
nfts but that that is an unbelievable
situation where people's like the third
like that piece of art is the third most
expensive
piece of art by a living artist
so wig but i want to go back a sec
because i saw you were talking firstly
really cool glasses
loving the the energy yeah yeah really
cool for me
you know i just want to make sure
everyone knows like you see you see
someone doing
news you see somebody on some kind of
live stream rocking
these glasses you know they're a chad
you know they hold bitcoin
so i just want to i just want to make
sure everyone understands shout out to
pit vipers
keep sending me these glasses i'm gonna
keep wearing them let's go
why didn't you wear those on fox because
i saw you on fox which i want to talk
about but why weren't you wearing those
on fox
i tried they make me take them all they
like it no they won't let me they won't
let me do anything
they won't even talk about my book
they've never mentioned the name of my
book once
well we're going to talk about that but
i want to go into nfts first okay
so what is going on why like where's the
value
okay jack's selling his and jack's
selling his tweet
what it what is that i can just
screenshot it and then bam my habit like
would you pay
that much money for it for a tweet nft
all right so let's step back a second
there are all kinds of people in this
world that like to collect things
and when i was a young kid i like
collecting baseball cards and i still
have baseball cards now
you may have collected things i don't
know but those things had value to you
and you may trade them with your friends
uh you may actually try to sell them and
i did all of those things with baseball
cards as a young kid i collected
coins proof sets all kinds of things
like that
so it's very natural for me to be drawn
to digital
collectibles whether it's in-game
purchases
digital assets you can own you can gift
to your friends
you can pull them out of the game you
can sell them if they're rare you can
just keep them
so that you look like an og in the game
i mean all this stuff like makes a lot
of sense to me
then you have the advent of digital
pokemon cards potentially there's
ether mon that's come out you've got
decentral land which is like
buying digital real estate i've even
looked at projects now that are doing
digital franchising so you can
buy some type of revenue generating
digital
asset and place it into central land and
get
paid you've got nba top shots now
and then you have art right so we're
talking about a 370 billion dollar
give or take industry uh the collectible
industry as a whole
so it's real um an art
is like a ballers kind of place right
you graduate from collecting baseball
cards and matchbox cars to collecting
real art maybe rare porsches stuff like
that
and you've got someone like beeple um
really interesting artist
has a really um i think intense
following people have bought into his
story
these everyday projects he's been only
in the space for like five months
right he's been a digital artist for a
long time 3d artist but
been in the space for five months and he
starts dropping like
absolute fire people are rushing to get
him
and then you have today and
yeah yeah hold on let me let me just
close this up you have an ethereum based
project an nft non-fungible token erc
721 contract
and uh he drops his piece of art for 69
million dollars
yeah it's it's mad but have you seen the
backlash that's happening and this is
actually something that i only saw
yesterday
um but it's mainly coming from the
transgender community
and i couldn't believe it i couldn't i
couldn't i was just like what
we just like jumped worlds here so
there's
okay so there's two things the first
thing there are issues with regards to
energy but that's always an issue that
we hear and a concern when it comes to
bitcoin so that one i don't care about
that one i'm like
i'm like whatever that's fine but the
second one was that apparently people
are taking other people's art
and they're minting it into an nft and
they're making money from that so
how on earth do you stop against that
and then also what happens
if i decide to nft
or min an nft of your tweet isn't
there some copyright issues here or am i
missing something
no look i i saw melton was getting all
uh kind of like tweaked and triggered
because people were minting her tweets
or something like that
and you certainly can take a screenshot
of
one of these projects and mint it on
another platform
but here's the thing anything of value
is going to be exploited
and art has historically been ripped off
reproduced and and sold as something
it's not
it's very easy to do just a touch of
homework to say that
ferocious an artist sold
or transferred that piece of art to me
and you can see that
in terms of just the transactions on a
blockchain
and that that is the original
piece of art or asset that that's all i
have to say about that if you're if
you're going to screenshot like someone
did that this morning
i own a people and i said hey there were
271 of these and he
he took a screenshot and said now
they're 272.
my whole point is go ahead and try to
sell that you're
lying to someone i mean i definitely
agree with you in that this isn't the
first time that you can just copy and
paste somebody's work
um like we can talk about your book
because i want to talk about it i
haven't read it yet when i leave the
youtube
we're not going to talk i won't talk
about my book to anyone that hasn't read
my book
no you know i've got plans to read it
i'm getting it on kindle
i haven't prepared you know what i tell
people who don't know how to read just
rub it on your face or something it's
that good of a book
i'm leaving i'm i'm i'm leaving the uk
when when i leave
that's when i'm reading it right so can
you talk about it
we'll talk about it when you read it
sometime because i don't know what you
want
to talk about now it'll take you it'll
take you four hours
and hopefully it'll it'll be meaningful
to you it's the book nobody mentions
it's the funniest thing i've ever seen
it's a number one bestseller
since i launched it i'm selling these
things out of the back of my
out of the back of my trunk and nobody
will say the name of this book and i
love that it's uh it's grown to be
uh something you know kind of uh have
its own life so it's pretty cool
i've heard it's had a really good
reception as well like i hear people
talking about it all the time
on clubhouse it's it's going down really
well
how long did it take you to write well i
started it in the beginning of 2020
finished it in like november
uh brushed it up a little bit and i
think the launch was december 8th
december 8th or december 10th so it took
me almost a year
but i had i had it on my bucket list to
kind of write a book so it was kind of a
cool thing to do
why did you want to do it i don't know
like
uh i had the time like this
this 2020 being like stuck in this
basement was
a bit depressing so um you know i'm
someone who likes to
kind of move around in the world a
little bit and that stopped so why not
take the opportunity to
uh to write about what was going on so i
i think it's pretty cool
read the book you and i will we'll
circle back and we'll read it and we'll
talk about it i'd enjoy that
i'm ready like i have it all prepared on
my kindle that's kind of like my plan
when my life is just karma
i'm like i've got three books lined up
yours is one of them
um what's going on with you
you're planning to uh to leave um the uk
i mean
let's let's talk about that a little bit
yeah we can yeah i mean
i i don't like the uk at all i've never
felt a connection with
british people unfortunately um i'm now
about a connection with
um the country i'm from london i've
never felt a connection with london at
all
so i'm just going well why is it
political or what what's the lack of
connection i mean i don't
not feel a connection to the united
states
yeah it's a really good question um
i would say gosh it's such a good
question i mean
i would say it's political to some
extent um
so london is like a very liberal kind of
lefty
environment and that doesn't it's not
really in line with with
kind of the way i look at things um and
so a lot of people my age
are all all very much like that and i've
been privileged enough to travel the
world and i've seen so many different
cultures
and so many different um people the same
age as me that just look at the world
the way i look at the world
um and then i came to sort of realize
this is definitely like a london
england kind of thing and then i have
the problem whereby i don't know if
you can relate to this but i have this
problem whereby when you're born and
bred from in london
it's really really hard to go anywhere
else in the uk
it's really hard it's like um it's like
a london-centric
thing like when you're a londoner you
you either leave the uk or you stay
well what why don't you go anywhere
around london in such a big city or
has uh like a cultural epicenter i mean
what what's the
what's the reason that you guys uh have
this big chip on your shoulder
yeah we do it like we're they're such a
north-south divide
um so even even with the with the the
manchesters and
the leads and from where you're from but
absolutely like i think
it's because london's not just the
financial you know center
but also the nightlife is better there
are more there are more bars there are
more restaurants
there's just more to do like if you okay
anyone who's listening who's not from
london don't get offended so here we go
it's kind of the way london londoners
look at it it's like you're
like downgrading if you leave because
there's just more there's just more in
london there's more options there's more
job opportunities
but i don't really care for it anymore i
think london underground is filthy
it's overpriced um and the people are
really unfriendly
so where where have you decided to kind
of
uh go next okay so i don't want to say
it publicly just yet
but i'm looking at the middle east at
the moment
um but i don't want to say it too
publicly my
end goal is an island that sounds cool
look and the middle east is a place a
lot of uh
people from the uk hang out right yeah
like
my brother actually just spent about
three months in the middle east um he's
in america now which is very cool so
americans be careful
my brother's arrived he's very
disruptive um
he arrived in lax last night so he's
very disruptive so be careful
um but yeah where were you lost in the
uk um
i don't know a year or two ago i mean it
wasn't it wasn't too long ago
yeah i was there on business i was in
london and uh
i like it very much i think the
skyline's a little weird it's always uh
peculiar you guys have weird like
egg-shaped buildings and stuff
the guy i think it's called the gherkin
yeah i don't know
i don't even know what it is never been
in it but i was riding in the train i
was like this is the weirdest looking
like
uh like montage of weird buildings
yeah i mean i don't know like london's
just it you know what it's filthy it's
overpriced and it's super liberal lefty
and i just gotta get out of here
basically and the and the
the weather's terrible so it does rain a
lot i always clown you on that
it does it does but i want to i want to
get your thoughts on bitcoin because you
know
we're almost at 60k and your last price
prediction um was wrong
which was was fun
wait which which price prediction did i
have that was wrong
the halloween one the all-time high on
halloween
you can't you can't legitimately say
that i missed that price prediction yes
it was all over it it hit like two weeks
later
it was true it made the prediction two
years before
october 31st 2020. okay
come on come on how was it feel like
fish was it was it all right it wasn't
much of a penalty
no it was disgusting like i i really
it's not something i would ever eat
um and i i thought yeah it was
it was pretty gross it was pretty gross
you tried i grew up on uh yeah i grew up
on them you grew up on eating filet of
fish from mcdonald's
come on i don't believe that i did no i
did i did my mom used it she used to
tell me that mcdonald's was helpful you
really do like that
yeah well i don't what i do is i'm
really weird though i do this with
burgers as well like i remove all the
bread all the sauce and i just eat like
the meat and the fish on its own
um that's the only reason why i like
them all right otherwise i won't eat all
the bread
yeah maybe if it was hot if it was
hotter and uh
i maybe had some suggestion of a type of
sauce to put on it but it's nothing i
want to i wanted to do again
so yeah to your point i didn't get it
exactly right
i ate the filet of fish but i still
chalked that up as a win
everybody that put that investment on
made money yeah
i mean yeah everyone
okay so when 60k what's happening 160k
and when 100k um because your price
predictors are on it let's say it
yeah i appreciate that so i um and jul
in january like january 28th
i told everyone would be the price today
so we hit that
right the big red circle is going to hit
somewhere in there
when will we hit 60k you know uh
i think tomorrow tomorrow
yeah i think tomorrow i think yeah i'm
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure we hit 60k on the 12th
on the 12th what's the date today the
11th okay
tomorrow i think we hit tomorrow 60k
i mean i don't know how how more
specific i could be
i actually love that if we do i'm if we
do then like
it's like crazy right it's clowntown
yeah you're going to be looking for
classes so you'll be on it can you send
me a pair of those
yeah you read my book and yeah the next
time
we talk you'll wear yours i'll wear mine
and we'll be able to see eye to eye like
we will have that
yeah we will disconnect though i feel a
bit of a disconnect so i can't see your
eyes
i know i know it was a late night i had
a soccer match last night
i didn't go to bed till like after
midnight i was on clubhouse
i think it's a wild place like there's a
lot of weird stuff going on a lot of
paid shills and implanted agendas and
stuff so you have to
you have to go in there with like like
tough as nails like it was the first
time i ever was like
openly confronted by one of these
anonymous virgin trolls who lives in
their mom's basement
you know he he decided to start
screaming well he started screaming in a
room with like 400 people that like i'm
a scammer
and a coiner and all that and and i
was in there with bitcoin tina
and hoddle and a bunch of like
maximalists
so you know i didn't know how to deal
with it you know
what did you do well getting in a like
text battle with someone is a lot
different than having someone just
screaming like a maniac
uh in their phone so you know my
my i think i said very gently
and very calmly and i tapped into my
british
uh kind of uh like elite
refined amazing
dude you're from you're a mancunian not
from manchester
very yeah very very elite
and i said look um
if you want to fight me i will pay you
500 000 we'll go anywhere
you know i'll go anywhere in the world
i've never seen you you've seen me
i'll donate the 500 000 to whomever you
want whom
ever you want right whomever you want
three rounds five minutes virgin nerd
i'm gonna put my hands on you i've never
seen you
yeah i've never seen you virgin nerd
but we're gonna dance together it'll be
fun i say it'll be fun it's all for fun
but what was his problem i don't get it
i don't understand because uh because
i'm done
i'm an investor in block five he thinks
i'm a scammer
scamming people and that uh i own uh i
have an investment in the digital asset
index fund
that it's one of the products that we
had at morgan creek digital
uh like i i you know
i don't even understand what he's
talking about i manage hundreds of
millions of dollars professionally for
public pensions
those are illiquid investments i can't
come out of them
and i don't personally own that i have
nobody also you shouldn't have to
you don't you will that's what i'm
saying it's just a it's a silly argument
you know and i have a lot of respect for
these folks who saw bitcoin early
and got into that investment um but that
doesn't mean they're smart
and it doesn't mean that they they're
you know they're good human beings like
none of that so you know i i wish him
well
and i'm half joking about dancing with
him for three rounds
but i'd watch it i'd watch it yeah look
leah at some point you know if i go to
miami and they're there we're gonna run
into each other
you know and i'm gonna see that five
foot six virgin
trying to take a shot at some you know
bearded woman
and i'm gonna walk up to him wait why
bearded woman wait go back they don't
get that reference
i don't know i just feel like that's how
you say it the kind of
like woman he probably would have a shot
at
i say i'm with you i'm with you i'm
following you yeah i can and i'm
identifying
you know as a transgender or whatever
right now so i feel totally comfortable
having this conversation you're such a
troll it's really interesting
it's really really interesting because
you're like a grown ass man with like a
wife and kids
yeah you come on and you just troll so
hard it's really
because because most people in your
position are really professional
no i know but like in a troll way i just
want to have fun like 99
of the stuff i'm saying like i'm
laughing through life
life is really hard people have
tremendous pain
and if we just smile a little bit and
laugh at ourselves like
half of or 99 of the jokes that i make
i just make fun of myself and i enjoy it
but
i mean for me to make a meme uh that i'm
a gig of chad
blowing through blowing tinder dates
backs out is the funniest thing in the
world
because i don't have any tinder dates no
i love it no i think it's great i like i
think it makes you actually makes you
quite untouchable
and actually it's something that i
really like because there are so many
trolls online and the best thing to do
is believe it or not in some ways rise
to it
like be just as troll troll-ish back
like don't
don't try and defend yourself because
that doesn't work don't try and like
be the good person it doesn't work leia
i think when you have strong opinions
and you certainly do um you have to also
have
like a strong constitution
right you you have to be able to take on
the push right so when you push hard
against the earth the earth
pushes earth pushes hard against you and
and i think you have that
you you enjoy that you enjoy these
strong opinions and positions and i
think the earth will push hard against
you you have to be prepared for that
you don't want to get blown off the
earth especially by
people who have loose opinions or will
say gutter ass to you excuse my
language
like why let that affect you
you're brilliant you're accomplished
you you're you're you want to learn i
think you're very
open-minded you and i don't agree on
tons of stuff
i think we get along great
no i'm with you i appreciate that and i
really appreciate that i'm with you who
fought for my peoples i was listening i
didn't know what's coming next
but wait i have a question about bitcoin
maximalism for you
so firstly are you a bitcoin maximalist
um honestly
and secondly so bitcoin maximalists
have kind of this um this aura whereby i
think they feel like they're the
gatekeepers of the world and they're
trying to protect
everybody make sure nobody gets scammed
and so on and so on
even if somebody's not shilling anything
they're just like even the fact that you
you had the courage to mention another
word that isn't bitcoin is just
horrendous anyway so
do you think it actually comes from a
good place do you think they're actually
trying to protect people
even though there's really not much um
that they're trying to protect from
particularly when
yeah you get my question yeah i think if
i showed up at the gate
of the the bitcoin maximalist citadel
and they the the you know they looked
over the gate
and they saw me out there they don't
open the gate so i i think
no matter i i don't think that they
would think i was a bitcoin maximalist
you know i talk about nfts i'm an
investor in block fi
you know i'm allow for my bitcoin to be
rehypothecated not
all of my bitcoin is in self-custody so
you get the picture here
um now do i think that they do good
absolutely
i think i think bitcoin maximalists are
like on a hero's quest
uh most of them have been but genuinely
though
genuinely let let me finish this because
there's gonna be douchebags and
and virgins and weirdos that just latch
on to it too because everyone wants to
be accepted
so you know if you have point zero zero
zero zero one bitcoin
and you wanna hang out with the bully
crowd then you could do that too
but most of them don't have anything do
you know that you don't think they have
anything
i don't no no i don't
i think i sit in rooms i think i sit in
rooms on clubhouse with
you know 10 15 mods who are teaching
people about finance that don't have any
fun
they have no financial success or track
record
you know i mean seriously i retired when
i was 26.
wow how did you do that i made a lot of
money
and was very focused that cannot be your
next book
as well that needs to be your next book
you should but i mean but
these little these little like shots if
i pull it out and i shoot it
i would want people to like say maybe i
should listen to this guy not lecture
him about why he's buying nfts right now
um but people would rather they would
rather scream at me like oh you're
you're a scammer you're playing hot
potato with people
okay i'm telling you that
i've seen four disruptive innovations in
my life
four one yeah my own company
fast med that i started when i was at
yale dropped out built a company
sold for 500 million bucks two the
internet
you know i'm there where all the smooth
brainers were yuck yuck
on tv about like what's the internet
what's this
i saw that today i saw that yesterday
though did you see
it was going around like yeah it's crazy
but i saw it in real life
it's like nut jobs like laughing about
it right the internet's not gonna be
anything
three bitcoin bitcoin alone is another
one of these amazing innovations you're
talking about
you know potentially becoming the
world's global reserve currency
amazing store of value as this this kind
of evolving asset
four i'm throwing in there nfts
oh well i don't know i really do yes
and i don't know i'm agnostic to
platform like i'm not
promoting ethereum or promoting wax or
ethernet or super farm or i don't know
who's gonna be right
i don't know who's gonna be right but
digital assets
are amazing like they are like this
whole thing about being able to
trade digital assets near
instantaneously
transfer money uh over blockchain
and then certify provenance and
i think is amazing and authenticity it's
a really big deal
to a nerd like me who's not a brother
who's not a virgin i'm happy for you i
didn't think he was because you have
a few kids yeah it's not my mom's
basement not a virgin
not my mom's basement you know the women
i'm with
all of them all four my wife and none of
them have a beard
that's what i'm talking about that's my
level up nerds
i'm talking about you anyway can we get
at all one day of the house
yeah of course well maybe i people
wanted me to do that
but i'm worried about security like i
don't want yeah either inside floor plan
of the house
yeah okay i take that back sorry yeah no
no worries i am potentially doing
a sh i'm potentially doing a show though
okay i've been asked to check a pilot
yeah like reality tv or yeah it's like a
reality tv
show about art like rich people buying
art
but they want to introduce crypto into
it like a subplot
okay wait when's this happening i don't
know i'm supposed to talk to people
uh tomorrow and kind of find out the
money because i'm not doing stuff for
free like i'm not willing to even shoot
a pilot for free
yeah i don't yeah but i mean if they're
gonna do the rolls-royce private jet
like put me in a nice suit and make make
believe that
i'm an art art dealer like i'm in like i
i'll stick with like i'll splash this
beautiful smile
and this olive skin i'll bring it on tv
we could do this
this is like mtv cribs meets crypto
meets 2021 style basically i saw
i saw the pilot it's wild these people
are
wild these are deals i love it they
they're beaut they're beautiful and
weird
you'll fit right in but wait i have two
questions i have two questions i want to
ask you the first one i want to go back
because
so you mentioned four key things that
happened right
how do you spot them like how do you how
do you know nfts is the thing because
gary vee said the similar said a similar
thing he was like yeah i just
i knew it when i saw it with the
internet i knew it when i started with
social media i knew it
and he feels the same with nft so how do
you spot that
oh he's got the glasses back on well
part of it is every one of these
situations leia was
met with violent opposition that's how i
know
so i'm i'm hugely emotionally invested
in whatever it is
and then when i battle test it or
pressure test it the world is going
ape that it's wrong i'll take you
back
i'm a physician assistant i'm doing my
residency at yale and i'm thinking oh
i want to hire a bunch of doctors and
bring a retail spin to healthcare
people were like that's the worst idea
i've ever heard it'll never work
no doctor is going to work for a pa
nobody's going to go
near a starbucks to get their health
care absolutely wrong
like every every counter thesis totally
wrong
and built it into a huge industry which
then continued to uh to grow and exist
today
as a huge part of infrastructure around
the world urgent cares and primary care
is using allied
healthcare professionals are a massive
business two
the internet you know i won't get into
it but you understand
the opposition that was there by the
intellectuals
they thought it was insane and when you
started to hypothecate like
people will be buying groceries or
ordering
uh ordering things that you would
traditionally buy from a store
online like that was clown town like
nobody believed that that would happen
i always underestimate how dramatic this
change would be
for people like you because i
i grew up i was born in the 90s digital
natives
yeah so but i i mean i remember i had my
first
mobile phone it was a nokia when i was
maybe
like tour no i was younger because i
used to get the school bus
so i was like i don't know 10 or
something like that
and even i've seen how it's changed and
i'm shocked yeah leia i mean
imagine growing up in the 1600s in new
amsterdam
i mean it was a tough world like it i
mean i was there and i was tell me
honestly
no no i'm like this is amazing and then
it became
seriously no it's uh
yeah insane you didn't have phones when
you were teenagers like
you didn't have any social media like
dating was all face to face like even
that's bizarre you had to spend games no
amazon
you had to be an absolute giga chad
baller that could walk up to a girl
and say you know hey what's up or would
you like to go get coffee or you like go
out for dinner
and then you had to continue to converse
with her like you know
i mean imagine all that imagine all that
um right
the things we've lost tough stuff no
there were no cell phones
people had bag phones and those bag
phones were
completely impossible you would never
ever use that phone
there were car phones but they were
weird they were like connected by like a
wire and they were only in like ferraris
and stuff
oh okay yeah they were um and then there
were no personal computers people had
word processors
the word processor the word processor
then had an led
screen that was the evolution so you
could actually spell check
those are the ballers and then uh
my freshman year college personal
computers came out macintosh
and uh what year was that 1992.
oh okay yeah yeah so then
yeah a long time ago and um 1994
the internet you know imagine i'm
growing up
there was no computers no computers
and then the internet aol um
dial-up internet connections i mean but
you want to talk about an amazing
like experience life experience to which
i'm sure
if i was talking to my grandmother she'd
say the same thing but for me
as a kid growing up and then
experiencing this expansion of knowledge
and technology has been it's been
mind-blowing i mean
no cell phones to bag phone
to internet it wasn't bad
it was literally a phone in a bag you
would carry around that was like a
it was like almost like a satellite
phone
i know about the bricks i know about the
big bricks you guys used to have no no
it was before that there was a bag
with a phone in it i don't know why it
was in a bag
but it was okay i've never heard of this
in my life internet
personal computers and think about the
people
elon musk jeff bezos uh
uh uh bill bill gates bill gates uh
steve jobs that's that's all that's all
my peer group
that's all my peer group like these
these guys are all right around the same
age
and they made all the cool right so
on top of the internet they built these
companies
um and now we've got rockets flying to
space
i got starlink for my birthday you know
i'm seeing like crazy stuff i'm booking
flights to go to the moon
i added yeah i added on my bucket list
that i'm gonna drive a you know drift a
lunar rover
on the moon you know all that kind of
stuff so
this is exciting times yeah i think it's
i think it's so insane like
even i just think we underestimate how
fast everything's changed
like even when i was younger i used to
run home from school and fight with my
brothers about who can go on msn first
to think like you had to go on msn to
speak to somebody instantly and there
was one computer to do it
as opposed to just i mean my phone's
like right here you know as opposed to
just like
texting is is insane um but
i wanted to ask you because we kind of
went past it
100k for bitcoin last just like been
floating in my head the whole time
can we get that kind of prediction from
you and then also max kaiser says at the
end of this year it'll be 200k
so yeah give us your thoughts 100k in
october
100k in october what 31st uh
yeah 100k but this is this is super
conservative
i mean uh i'm going to be way off and
low i'm saying 100k
by october 31st but i don't really
believe that
at all i was expecting 100k this month
i'm disappointed
yeah no no i but i don't i i think that
we get
far beyond 100k by october 31st but i'm
going with 100k by october 31st
we smashed that 300k
we smash 100k okay we smash 100k
i mean i i love the super cycle chart
that shows two million dollar bitcoin
march 21st 2022.
oh wow i haven't seen this yeah but that
that that seems like an impossibility
intellectually
because the market cap of bitcoin would
have to be so huge like
um that i i just don't see how it gets
there but
it's fun to explore so i know that you
have a time limit because you have to go
somewhere um how long do we have because
i have another question for you
um stop at 12 20.
12 20. oh that's in like four that's in
four minutes is that i can't see
uh you get oh 12 20. 12 20. i know we've
got like 15
yeah okay well 15. okay cool so i wanted
to quickly ask you about gold because um
you've been on fox you've
done really well on fox so congrats i
saw you with david goxten and then you
were obviously with peter schiff as well
so let's talk about peter schiff because
his son went a hundred percent
um of his portfolio into bitcoin
why can't peter schiff get on board what
is going on and actually gold is down
i was reading today more than 17 percent
in the last six months
it go gold is dumb like it's wrong i
don't even understand like
um as a as a store of value asset
it's not working anymore and eventually
peter's going to get caught in a short
situation where people start to short
gold as the kind of capital
just flows out of it and flows into
bitcoin as a bet that's the better store
of value
just as i was talking about the bag
phone and you're kind of smirking and
giggling about it and it's
even impossible for you to understand i
feel like young people feel that way
about gold like
i just can't imagine you saying you know
what i'm gonna go
and buy a safe and i'm gonna bolt the
safe to the wall and the floor
and then i'm gonna load the safe with
like i don't know
kilos of gold and silver like i don't
even think you want your life to be
that tied down let alone lugging a
pallet of
silver around it makes no sense
yeah i mean i think you make a really
interesting point about you're not
wanting your life to be that tied down
because i think we're life is just
changing with with you know even with
this whole corona virus the fact that
you can now work almost from anywhere in
the world there's a huge push to get
everybody online
um we're moving to this globalist you
know this global
no borders kind of world where you can
work from anywhere do
you know just work from wherever you
want do whatever you want
and also a lot of people less and less
are seeing the value in
buying a property not just because they
can't get on the property ladder
um but also they're just not seeing the
value in it um
and so yeah i mean where are they gonna
where are they gonna put their gold
anyway
like i don't have i i don't plan on
buying a house at all
for a for a long long even if i could or
can maybe not maybe i can afford it it
doesn't matter
i don't want to buy one at all but
leia is that because you don't want to
be tied down or is it because you think
about things
in bitcoin like price things in bitcoin
it's two things so firstly like i don't
want to be tied down and even
when i'm married i also feel like the
kind of person that i would choose
i don't really want to be fully tied
together i don't want to be you know
tied to a country i'd want to be able to
like
move with him and go wherever we want to
go in terms of
in terms of bitcoin i also don't want to
sell it i like i don't want to sell it
but michael and michael has been talking
about taking a loan out on your bitcoin
and so on and so on i don't understand
that so can
maybe you explain that yeah i i think um
and i'll go back to the 1600s in new
amsterdam
so if we were fortunate no but i'm
serious pl play the game with me if we
were
if you and i had arrived there and then
i was able to project forward
history uh into the future with you and
say hey
this is going to eventually be new york
and every piece of land here will be a
city block
and we can buy those city blocks right
now for 500
and you and i had wealth because we came
from
wherever the new amsterdam people came
and we bought a bunch of city blocks
everybody that owns
new york city blocks never sold those
new york city blocks
now that's a pretty illiquid asset but
it
is priceless so how do you
pass this priceless illiquid
asset on to the next generation the next
generation next generation
you have to use leverage you have to be
creative you have to do things to
maintain it but profit from it that's
what we
all will do with bitcoin like you'll
borrow against your bitcoin you'll put
it in an
oh how do you do that well you could do
it right now with block fi
you can you can take a loan uh you can
pledge
like 50 loan to value and you can pull
cash out and you can do something with
that cash now i don't necessarily
recommend that people do that
but i'm saying it's a certainly an
option to do the other thing you can do
is you can
gain interest on your bitcoin
so you can earn money on it that way but
you should just continue to think about
how rich people
protect their assets and take illiquid
assets
and make them work for them and work
beyond just appreciating
right because bitcoin is not only
good money it's sound money but it's
also this
amazing like apex predator asset that
can grows
and has grown 200 percent historically
year-over-year
um uh and i i just think it's an amazing
thing
you don't want to sell it and i
appreciate you saying that
you know you you hold like you do um
but uh yeah i have no interest in
selling like seriously i have no
interest and i just i've only because
obviously i'm not american i've only
recently heard the term 401k um because
i
we don't have that here we have our own
um equivalents
um i don't want any of that i don't want
any of it like the amount of tax that
you have to pay when you want to
remove it i've seen too many bad things
happen
to generations before me so i
i'm just like no i i don't do you have a
retirement plan right now
bitcoin yeah i get it
and i was gonna say i'm sorry to
interrupt you like you're
you have a lot of different revenue
streams through your show
and sponsors etc do that don't ever feel
bad about that
and get paid in bitcoin or convert that
fiat into bitcoin i mean i know you're
doing that
bravo come into the rooms
in in clubhouse that i'm in that are
rooms about capitalism and how to
uh make money and not just you know
shame people that are holding you know
that that
uh don't just hold bitcoin i i mean
that's fine
if that's what you want to do but i
think there's there are other people
looking for
mechanisms that grow faster than bitcoin
and there there are
ways and strategies to to uh to make
money
greater than 200 percent annual
so i love it well ping me in i want to
come in i want to learn
i'm always happy to to learn more so
yeah ping me in
that's cool that's cool all right well
look i appreciate
this uh i hope i was a good fill-in
uh who who was slacking today that was
supposed to be here that you called on
me
so firstly thank you so much for joining
this has been super fun it's been really
chilled i know it has like it's been
really chilled i really like it and i
was going to prepare but you told me not
to prepare and i'm glad i didn't this
has been really fun
um a girl called an old school i know
how to talk to a woman
i see i see there you go that's that's
that's what you did
it was supposed to be um dominique
samuels who's a really cool
person she's british and she's really
into
the politics scene she's mixed race and
she's very much
auntie blm um and so has some really
really cool views so i was excited to
chat to her but
a last minute pull out so but yeah it
was great having you on so i want to
thank you so much and i want to thank
everybody for watching
and really quickly where can people find
you and what
are you up to where can people find you
well i would like to
if you would have me if you ever have
someone who
is coming on your show that has extreme
thoughts like that i would love for you
to have the two of us on
and i would never be confrontational but
both as a learning experience because
anytime i hear you know people that have
a different opinion than me i like to be
around them
i would enjoy uh asking questions
in a non-confrontational environment
where i could learn or maybe challenge
someone whom
i think uh maybe has it wrong and maybe
i do too
so yeah absolutely cool absolutely
thanks so much for coming on and thank
you everybody for watching we'll see you
next week bye
see ya
[Applause]